[Music]
you noticing the presidential ads the
presidential campaign ads are already on
the air
yeah they're bombarding us already the
election is until November uh-huh well
in a new campaign ad I don't know if you
saw this it just came out the Obamas are
on camera and they say that on their
first date they saw Spike Lee's do the
right thing that's in the ad yeah
meanwhile I met in Ann Romney's first
state they saw a guy who looked like
Spike Lee and immediately called the
police
[Applause]
Obama is really going after Romney this
is the latest President Obama called
Mitt Romney a pioneer of outsourcing
jobs yeah a spokesman for Romney said I
dare him to come to India and say that
to my face
[Music]
you know this is Gary yeah
the Supreme Court has made a lot of
decisions today the Supreme Court has
affirmed that corporations can spend as
much money on political campaigns as
they want that's the ruling yeah yeah
you don't like it but this decision was
praised by Senator Chevron P Mountain
Dew
[Music]
yesterday thousands of people marched
through the streets of New York City for
the gay pride parade yeah or as New
Yorkers call it the outdoor Tony Awards
you're a Hillary Clinton did this is a
weird story last week Secretary of State
Hillary Clinton wore a string of Mardi
Gras beads to a swearing-in ceremony
yeah yeah the State Department called
Hillary's gesture light-hearted while
Bill Clinton called it twenty years too
late
[Music]
science news a new kind of cosmetic
surgery for women is out there removes
body fat and redistributes it to the
breasts yeah if you're interested in the
procedure just go to your doctor and ask
for the win-win
[Applause]
[Music]
why was that necessary no no we're in a
room okay that's a better explanation
than oh well I had fat taken out of my
ass and put in my tits
I like your explanations oh really
I thought Urich what beats that exploit
its fantastic just doesn't seem like
pillow talk
guess what I did here's a weird story in
Pennsylvania four people were arrested
for committing a drive-by water gun
attack
yeah if convicted they could face up to
two years in a federal bond C castle
[Applause]
[Music]
somewhere Dana Carvey is watching and
he's very happy yeah
or threatening to sue exactly what are
the other this is weird it's being
reported that Madonna Madonna has her
dressing rooms sterilized after she
leaves to remove all traces of her DNA
yeah which finally proves what I've been
saying since 1985 Madonna is a serial
killer
[Applause]
you are you all got on birth that
immediately a fire Madonna's people I'd
be worried that a random crowd right on
just that right on board with that well
they know why else would she need those
arms seriously you won't get free now